the Joe Rogan experience you know
certainly we don't i think the i have no
idea what your position on climate
change is but personally i think that
things are happening and something needs
to be done as clearly things are
happening and that you know there was i
read a couple of editorials probably in
the new york times or something a couple
of months ago one was about how yes the
you know things are changing and we have
a right to worry but you know we
shouldn't worry about the earth as you
know the famous quote is guy is a tough
[ __ ]
so the earth will survive but the
configuration of life on it is unlikely
to continue to be the same under those
conditions the more that everything
changes the conditions of life change
and the first things to go and this is
what happened to the dinosaurs or large
energy demanding organisms because as
the conditions change and you know the
the climate that we've lived in we've
succeeded because we were able to
benefit from that kind of climate but as
the climate begins to change our kind is
not going to be able to succeed as well
because those conditions are you know
the waters are rising the deserts are
expanding all these things are happening
and it's just not going to be yeah
species don't last that long few million
years and they go so our time maybe
we've only been around for what three
hundred four hundred thousand years and
something well depend on what what we
call we yeah but you didn't the ender
dolls were around quite a bit longer
than that yeah they're not here anymore
so we don't have a i mean i think that
we can use our minds to try and you know
help us get through this but that's only
gonna work if we can do that
collectively that's the scary part we
have to work together collectively as a
world because these are not local issue
these are global issues yeah and that is
that a lot you know especially getting
other countries like China to comply
yeah but yeah you see that small
successes I mean like auto companies
deciding well we need to you know rein
in the emissions and they there's
probably a profit motive underlying that
at some point sure and people are
conscious there's green dollars Yeah
right like you wanna like when when you
think about technological achievements
and you think about the the conscious
mind and the ability to create in the
creative process do you envision the
possibility of some sort of a
technological solution to a lot of the
problems that we're facing I think it
has to be a social solution social how
so we have to we have to figure out how
to balance this worldwide it can't this
we can do whatever we want in this
country if we could do what we want but
you know if if even if we were the best
country in the world for the environment
that wouldn't sell in the problem you
know it's it's a worldwide problem you
know Amazon forest that's affecting a
lot of people you know it's just not a
it's not a simple thing that one country
can solve right but if one country takes
steps and imposes some sort of a
technological solution that pulls carbon
from the atmosphere that does enhance
some sort of a cooling process to bring
homeostasis to bring some sort of a like
generally agreed upon state of the
environment if that's technologically
possible I mean that's going to come out
of the creative mind right well you know
I don't want to go too far off into my
not area of expertise like climate and
Sol labs I just think there's I think of
it from the kind of the social
perspective and what our brains are
contributed but I don't wanna I don't
think I can really dress the details of
all that right but even like socially if
we did address it socially we're still
gonna have to deal with the actual
physical limitation right
of the just the environment that we live
in and what we've done this how do
somehow or another mitigate it yeah I
agree yeah so but yeah so I think you
know creators coming along and trying to
find technical solutions that's great
when you analyze the human mind and
knowing what you know about the thought
processes and the way people think and
work when you see people in denial of
climate change and when you see people
that are so enamored with the concept of
capitalism and big business that they
don't really think that it's a big deal
or they want to deny that it's a big
deal so that they can continue
short-term profits right what is that
like those mechanisms like why is
watching that take place in a monkey
mind yeah well what do you what are you
thinking when you see that happen with
humans I you know I don't think it's
simple it's not simply denial of climate
change for climate reasons I think
there's a lot of social you know within
certain groups there's social stigma for
being pro-environment yes
and so it's tribal tribal it's it's
people yet people cling together and
it's a kind of form of self-protection
that by identifying a set of issues that
we all can agree upon because they're
kind of dictated top-down in a sense
that or our thing and then that thing is
somebody else's things yeah yeah that's
a weird aspect of being a human being
right these tribal identity things where
if you're in this group you must be
pro-choice and if you're in this group
you must be pro-life you must be
anti-war you must be pro Second
Amendment you know there's very little
deviation and and that that's left right
that's everything I mean that belief
systems rigid belief systems you know
part of just part of being and when you
look at politics and you know that these
police systems are when do you find it
odd that we have these like sort of
polar opposite
at least left/right choices red blue
choices that we've limited ourselves to
these very distinct tribes right and
that's yeah I think that's unfortunate
but that's where we are is there a way
out of that you know the political side
just have to take that one